well Sasha Walpole joins me now
a week ago I'd never heard of you no not
anybody else apart from your family and
friends and now you're like this
globally known person and actually
through no fault of your own or desire
to be publicly known at all no I know
it's been a bit of a whirlwind week and
hopefully it's a means to an end and I
can get back and back to normality go
back to work drive my Digger hide back
under my rock how do you feel about the
way this has all exploded in your life
um very surreal still doesn't seem real
kind of shocked really I didn't think
that it would hit the headlines like it
did I mean there's a lot of worse stuff
going on in the world right now that
probably needs more of a focus whereas
we have the earthquake
um and a few other things going on the
war in Ukraine and
but yeah I never thought it would
happen like it has
I mean it's been a fascinating thing to
watch on Phil because I used to run a
national newspapers so I knew exactly
what would happen the moment Harry put
in this book the details of how he lost
his virginity to an older woman in a
field behind the back of a pub I just
thought well I know what's happening now
every single news desk in fleestry and
every TV network they're all sending
people off to try and find this poor
woman who is probably never said a word
about this and now is going to be on the
front page of papers from here to
America to China to Timbuktu
yeah it is I mean I had a bit of a
running with the paparazzi back in 2001
um so I kind of knew how it can turn out
um
and at first I was a bit like nope just
hide it'll be fine it'll go away like I
have done you know in the past and then
suddenly realized that it's getting
closer your world's getting smaller
um a lot more people are talking about
it
um you know friends from back home are
getting questioned accused and I was
just like you know what the way to stop
it is just come forward and say it's me
and then hopefully no sooner it's come
out it'll go and I can carry on with my
little life when was the first moment
that you knew that you were in this book
um when my friend sent me a screenshot
of a comment
um via what what's happened I was just
that way so for watching telly and yeah
I kind of didn't quite know what to do
about it we had it we shocked were you I
was yeah scared about what may happen to
you or um disbelief disbelief you went
into so much detail um because then it's
obvious who it was so for me that was
like a huge thing because then said I
was like oh no everyone's gonna know
um and then yeah next day all the
messages started I'm trying to imagine
what it must be like when we played the
clip of Harry I don't know if we can
play it again but we played the clip of
Harry talking about this I just want to
sort of look at you as you listen to
this because I'm trying to imagine what
it was like to have been you yeah when
he came out with this not just in
written word but also in spoken word
this is a guy who's sixth in line or bit
in line to the to the throne of this
country talking about losing his
virginity to to you yeah Sasha well boys
take a listen
I suspected he was referring to my
recent loss of virginity in glorious
episode with an older woman she liked
horses quite a lot and treated me not
unlike a young stallion quick ride after
which she'd smack my rump and set me off
to Grace among the many things about it
that were wrong it happened in a grassy
field behind a busy Pub
what did you feel when you you heard
this I don't really know I can see the
humor side of the horse because
obviously
well not at the time
um but I I was agreeing
um I had left High Grave by the time
this had happened right but yeah I just
I don't know I could see the funny side
to it you know
we were two friends and for me I still
see him as Harry I still see him as a
friend that I used to hang out with down
the pub
um you know go and watch the polo with
and yeah it was just seeing pictures of
you of you both there with some other
friends clowning around and stuff I mean
I suppose the my response to it when I
first heard about this was I thought it
was breath I've got to be honest
breathtakingly hypocritical as someone
who goes on and on about privacy to then
reveal such a private thing but not just
about himself but to inevitably spark
the trail of interest that would lead to
your door without even having the good
grace to let you know he was doing it
yeah
I mean if if you want to live a private
life and you want to get out of the the
Limelight and leave the royal family or
whether to live your life as you want to
live it
um to then sell a book and go on Netflix
is kind of going against what you're
saying you want
um but yeah I just have nobody he didn't
call you or none of his guns nobody
contacted you to say you're in the book
no the First Union was a friend
whatsapping you yep to say well this is
you yeah yeah we were like oh my God I
was yeah well I think I've probably used
A Little Bit Stronger language I almost
fell off my sofa but yeah it was just
you know and then obviously all the
jokes come in about all young Stallion
and the older lady and I mean what
language he used that I thought was
actually quite disrespectful it was kind
of like it was all wrong you're an older
woman treating him like a stallion it
was all yeah I think it's just the way
that it's written you know the thing
wrong about it we were two friends it
should never have happened we crossed
the line it was never intentional there
was nothing before nothing after
um
I mean Inglorious it's not really that
glorious sleeping with someone in a
field behind a pub when you're I don't
know your moments
yeah sometimes
would you agree it was Inglorious then
or
um you know there is nothing glorious
about being drunk and then coughing off
with one of your mates in the field I
don't know actually Sasha I did that
loads of times when I was young always
felt pretty glorious at the moment it
was the next morning there was a problem
yeah I think that's probably what we all
found
let's go back I want to go back to where
it all started because it's kind of
fascinating that you were you've been a
groom at Highgrove like you said but you
frequented this local pubs there were
two pubs in there so tell me about the
two pubs yeah I mean we used to drink at
the Battle bone quite a lot which is
obviously mentioned quite a lot
um and then we used to go to the vine
tree and there was another one the vine
tree was the crime scene yep that's
where the uh the crime took place yep
but you would go in these pubs and it
was perfectly normal that Harry and
William in fact who was in the pub
actually on my night in question but
they would both come down as young
princes and they'd hang out with you
guys yeah I mean I don't even think
it's like I said before it was just a
group of friends so it didn't matter if
you're a prince a rider a groom a polo
player we were just like we had horses
in common and we just hung out any other
Royals go in there
um not really I think Zara may have
popped in once or twice but it was just
mainly William Harris that was their
local no sign of Uncle Andrew no sign of
Uncle Andrew just as well probably yeah
um but but the so the atmosphere was
very relaxed even though they were
Royals and you were the Royal groom or
had been and the others were just local
it didn't really matter what what class
you were from no part of society they
didn't care no one cared no at the end
of the day you can't be a polar player
without a groom because if you haven't
got someone doing your horses you can't
play polo right and it's the same I grew
up in a pub pubs are pretty you know
egalitarian places like anything goes
right yeah it doesn't matter whether
you're rich you're poor you're this
you're that it doesn't matter everyone
just mixes in in a pub yeah yeah it is
you know I I generally look back on my
years of teenage and young adulthood of
fond memories
yeah good fun a laugh you know luckily
it was before any social media and you
know camera phones well now it wouldn't
happen probably because there'd be too
many phones out yeah the Royals would I
mean sad for them but you know you
wouldn't better go to a local pub like
that probably no it is you know
you think he probably did have one of
the better times growing up because he
isn't growing up with social media he
isn't growing up with a camera phone in
his face what was he like that as I said
he was 16. you know fun Sparky he was
just one of the boys he was you know he
was a lad he was good fun to be around
yeah I mean this he was 16 which was
just been a few years after obviously
his mother died in this terrible tragedy
had you known him in the aftermath of
that and no I didn't I didn't get to
know him sort of until a bit later on
from that and to be fair he never ever
sort of spoke about it he you know he
just we just kept it light-hearted we
were just mates we just talked about
Polo horses going to the pub
um yeah and you become sort of quite a
good friends where he would ring up your
home yeah and he'd text you and stuff
yeah yeah generally if sometimes you
ring the landline and your mum would
answer me what did he call himself just
Harry yeah yeah Harry and yeah and then
we have a chat and then probably
arranged to meet up somewhere go and
watch the polo see what everyone else
was doing see what the plan make it
sound perfectly normal why did your mum
feel that Prince Harry was ringing a
daughter I don't know I think because
they knew that we all hung out in a
group and it wasn't really a big thing
back home
um yeah I think the first time I did it
she was a bit like what was that Harry
Harry and I was like yeah she said oh
how funny and that was about it really I
mean did you call him H like his wife
doesn't it
um no only in text messages maybe used
to sign off as H but I just thought
that's because you couldn't be bothered
to write Harry
and from what I could gather a lot of
drinking went on this Pub yeah I mean
well the knight in question I I read
that you'd had 10 shots is that right we
did between us it was a bit of a funny
night it was the night before my
birthday so I was actually 18. um but
yeah and I think and you'd had a
difficult problem because you've broken
up with this guy and he then rocks up in
the pub with his new girlfriend yeah
well he rocked up and then she rocked up
after and I think when she rocked up he
could sense that I was a bit oh that's
pretty crap so he then was like come on
let's you know light in the mood have a
laugh you know
um yeah and like I say it just what was
the shots
um I think it was a mixture if I'm
honest I don't think it was one was a
creamy ones for assume it was Bailey
yeah oh my God Bailey's Bailey's whiskey
sambuca really all going down yeah yeah
so he was a shoulder to cry on he
I think I mean I'm not one
for attention so I just kind of get on
with things but um yeah I just think
that he sensed that you know I'd not be
okay with that and
um sort of try just to lighten the mood
and have a laugh change change it's not
something he would do on a regular basis
um I think he generally was just trying
to make me and he had a birthday card
for you he did which he'd hand written
yeah we got it here I think and it said
dear sash have a very happy birthday and
don't get too pissed luckily I'll be
there to keep an eye on you loads of
Love baz yeah why do they call
themselves I have no idea but he always
used to sign himself off in different
ways H baz P.S thanks for everything
what do you think you meant by that it's
just as friends really I don't think
there's anything specific behind it we
just talking chatting but nothing about
anything in particular I think he was
just a nice comment to put in a card it
was also a toy that he gave me it was
yeah what was it Miss Piggy why I think
he won it at the thought Park that day
and just thought it'd be quite nice to
give it to you he won a prize and then
just decided to re-gift it yeah pretty
much yeah but that's a relationship it
was there was nothing I wouldn't even
expect a card or a Teddy it's just come
and celebrate and have a laugh at what
moment on that night
did things take a turn um um well
because you're great friends you've been
for ages we stuck out the back for a
cigarette
um and yeah just hold it there okay
we're gonna take a break and come back I
want to leave it on that dead
what happens after the cigarettes
well welcome back to my exclusive
interview with Prince Harry's first
lover Sasha Walpole who just to repeat
is only doing this because of him
putting it in his books Bear all about
this night at the pub
um so let's cut to the quick you're
having a little crafty bag out the back
yep what happened who makes the move
um he made move really yeah
um yeah I don't even really know why or
what happened we just want a cigarette
and then if we know it it was all
happening what was happening
um well he just started kissed me and
then before you know it it was all going
on you start kissing are you thinking
this is weird because you've been really
good friends here's Prince Harry yeah I
mean
I didn't see him as Prince Harry I see
him as Harry as a friend and I think
that's like quite a big difference
um and we are quite drunk so you just
yeah
[Music]
yep and then you get lost in the moment
and then before you know it it's yeah
and then you wake up and we've actually
got lost
yeah we get up and then this reality
kicks in yeah we're moving a bit too
fast here so you go from smoking out the
back of the pub to a field nearby yeah
any any particular reason or just um
Jeff people I think because believe me
his security guys with that right yeah
yeah car park try to give them
we had gone over the fence to have a
cigarette away from everyone because he
wasn't really meant to be smoking
um so yeah we just hopped over the fence
seemed like a good idea at the time and
the next thing I mean did you know as
you were
in flagrante in the field that he was
actually a virgin no I didn't no I don't
know why but I didn't even think about
it because it's never been on my mind
before when did you find out was it
actually was it only really confirmed by
the book no well I suppose to 100 but I
yeah you kind of people talk and then
the next day was apparent that yeah it
was his first you were the chosen one I
was indeed yes does it feel weird
talking about it it does because it's
just something that happened so long ago
and to me it's not a big deal I just
yeah it's one of those things it's quite
a big deal it is in the eyes of people
yeah I suppose but um like I said I just
seen him as a friend and if anything is
just you've overstepped that line with a
friend the entire uh Collision lasted
five minutes yeah probably at the higher
end of expectation for men of that age
or I think when they lose their
virginity but
um what happened was it awkward
afterwards he went back to the pub right
um yeah we kind of was like oh okay um
we decided to go separate ways so he
went one way I went the other trying to
make it look less obvious but it doesn't
really work where were the security
guards at that point they had realized
that he hadn't come out the pub because
it was closing time and yeah they were
looking for him and found him down the
road I think did they asked what had
been going on no no he was kind of taken
off and I went home so you left your
belt in the field I did yeah I had to go
back the next day when I collected my
cards to retrieve my belt and when you
saw your friends when you go back to the
pub yeah what did you say to them
um nothing there's quite a few giggles
and they kind of knew what had happened
and I think they probably knew what was
going on when
um the security had started looking for
him
um but yeah they just no one really said
anything I think everyone would just be
like keep quiet and carry on you wake up
in the morning
presumably quite hungover yep and then
is there that moment where you suddenly
go oh god I've just remembered yeah yeah
it's that cringe factor that Creeps in
and you're like oh no I've well and
truly overstepped the Mark
um yeah what did you think to do then I
mean anything did you try and contact
him no I thought I just need to go in
get my car I probably had to go to work
or get ready for work the next day so I
just wanted to get all my stuff it's my
birthday so I probably had plans that
day
um did you who did you tell about what
had happened um I told my sister and I
told my mum and how do they react
friends
um okay they didn't really phase my
sister yeah
yeah but they knew it was Harry they
weren't thinking immediately Royal
Wedding balcony scene we're on it I
think we're quite far from The Royal
Wedding
um but yeah no I think yeah my sister
you know she found it quite amusing
quite funny
um my mum you know she was just like oh
okay and yeah as long as I was safe and
happy and not in any trouble did your
dad know
um do you know I think I I brushed the
comment over but he would probably be
like not listening and it's not
something that I'm gonna go and make him
listen to I just want to be like yeah
yeah I said Harry and wandered off out
the door I was like I'm not gonna sit
him down and make him listen to what his
19 year old daughter had done
um so yeah
I mean the weird part of the story for
me is that you then have no more contact
with Harry at all having had this
friendship which then builds to this you
know thrilling to new Mark that's it you
never see or speak to him again no we
haven't we haven't I you know there's no
messaging there was nothing weird you
think I think it's because foot and
mouth was Rife that summer you know and
I think the Social Circles they weren't
happening as much because the polo
wasn't Polo wasn't happening nothing was
happening everything was grounded
everything was stopped
um you didn't naturally see each other
no no the you know in the normal group
of people that would have been buzzing
for the summer weren't here
um and at that point I then went to a
different nightclub we went over to
Oscars at Longley and I met my husband
there
um you know we got on and then my Social
Circle has moved to a different area did
you tell your husband I did yes um how
did you react Well he kind of knew
because it was not long after all the
the pictures came out and 2001 so it's
kind of all around the same time he
didn't really care yeah he was at face
I mean it's fascinating to me that this
is 21 years ago and that the last you
ever see of Prince Harry is immediately
after you've just had sex with him yeah
I know strange it's sort of random isn't
it it is I mean I don't know he was a
young boy so for him it may have been
Mega awkward
um you know it's two friends that cross
the line and it is always going to be a
little bit awkward but if it's your
first time then you're probably finding
it a little it would have been a lot of
people Sasha in your position because
you weren't from a wealthy family no
right you've never had huge riches or
anything
a lot of people might have been tempted
to have cashed in on their night of lust
with Prince Harry you never did why
because he was a friend
he was a friend I didn't see it like
that and you kind of feel protective
um not because of who he is but I'm like
that with all my friends
um but yeah I just
never occurred never crossed your mind
no not really but that's a decency
that's quite rare actually these days
yeah well you just some things are just
better left unsaid I mean there's an
army isn't it there's you
being decent and wanting to protect him
and his privacy yeah and yet it's only
come out because he actually did the
complete opposite in the book yeah yeah
I know it's um
you go back to the same thing of you
know if you if you want privacy don't
write about it don't speak about it
um but I don't know why he put it in his
book is it hypocritical do you think a
little bit yeah if I'm honest you know
it's something that he could have if
he'd just put oh oh you know about me
losing my virginity and left it at that
it would have been fine because no one
would have been on the wiser is the fact
that he added more to that story that
everyone was like haha that's you right
um and then it puts you in that position
so and it must be I mean a range of
emotions but one of them it must be
quite intimidating to be on the
receiving end of suddenly knowing you're
in this book which is one of the biggest
selling books in history yeah and
everyone's reading it and the media are
getting more and more excited about who
this person is and you know it's you
yeah so the clock is ticking to that
knock on the door it is yeah and it's
like
it's one of those at first you're in
denial you're like no I don't you know
it's going to be fine it'll pass over
and like I say the messages start coming
in everyone's starting talking about it
which then pretty much doubles is what
triples the people that know because
then everyone's like oh I know who that
was and if you know people are asking
you know family and friends oh yeah we
know who it is and then suddenly it's
just the reality of this isn't going to
go away forever this is going to flare
up until they know who it is they're
going to be questioning people and yes I
could not have said anything but then
it's never going to stop this is do you
think you should have had the the
matters honestly to just have let you
know it was going to be you could have
given me heads up of like you know I'm
going to put it in the book
um even if he didn't ask if it was okay
just at least give me an option of what
to do about it yeah yeah pretty much
let's take another break I want to come
back I want to get your view I don't
know what you think of the monarchy of
the royal family of the the late great
Queen King Charles and what do you think
about Megan and Harry now living this
life over in California what do you feel
about them because Sasha wall now we
want to know your views
we'll be back after the break but more
from my exclusively
well welcome back uh Sasha Walpole who
took Prince Harry's virginity is still
with me those words every time you hear
that must be weird right what did your
family make of it when it all blew up in
the last like two weeks um they're quite
calm quite
sort of okay my mum you my dad didn't it
wasn't until I had a bit of a
conversation with him it became apparent
he had no idea what it was on about and
then I spoke to mum and was a bit like
well I don't think Dad knows and she's
I'll just check and she's like no he
didn't know
um which was really awkward I mean
Harvard any dad but then his daughter's
all over the front page of the paper for
taking Prince Harry virginity there's
quite a moment to wake up to that yeah
especially when you know it's your
daughter at first you're just thinking
oh well okay and then when you realize
it's someone you know and love it's a
bit different but was he annoyed at
Harry no he wasn't I mean they're
massively supportive in their main
concern is I'm happy I'm safe
um they said they'll support me either
way whether I was to speak out or
whether advice to keep it a secret
either way they would try and do damage
limitation and just you know be there
for me your kids are too young they're
only five and three but how did your
husband react to it all being public
I think he was as shocked as me
obviously he knew about it so it was no
great big secret but um if he didn't
know it would have been probably really
awkward but yeah I think the fact that
he knew he just kind of laughed was like
oh what are we gonna do it's been an
amazing you know two years really for
the monarchy really since I think Prince
Philip died and then the queen died and
we've now got the coronation coming yeah
are you are you a big monarchist I am
yeah I do like a royal family yeah what
do you make of what's been going on with
them I think sad I think it's sad with
any family regardless if you're a Royal
or whoever as soon as there's a bit of
conflict in between family it's sad it
is sad I'm lucky I have a good family
and I have you know my sister's amazing
so we're all really close
um so I couldn't really imagine how they
would feel especially for you I mean
being in the pub with William and Harry
you've seen them young and obviously
very close then yeah particularly
probably the closest they've been was in
the aftermath of their mother's death to
see them now completely having this Rift
and completely apart that is really sad
I think it is yeah I mean
I've I've tried not to follow it too
much but I do feel that yeah like I say
with any family
um any conflict is sad because Life's
Too Short yeah life well if you were in
the pub with them now what would you say
to them Life's Too Short you know just
slightly differences and you know just
just chat but I probably would never be
in the pub with the two of them again
you never know you never know maybe you
never know I mean I think Harry owes you
a drink yeah just not a trash shots
what do you think of Meghan Markle is
bright I mean again I share a lot in
common I mean we do yeah we beg to
reform as H
um but yeah I don't I don't know I just
I I mean he's gone from a digger to a
gold digger
yep you could like that
um I don't know like I said I I sit on
the fence I don't know the lady
um I wish him all the best I wish him
the happiest does he seem happy to you
um he's not the boy that I remember
that's for sure but again I'm not in his
shoes I have no idea what's going on in
his head I haven't seen him for 21 years
but you know
you but you make your own happiness do
you have a view of Megan
I don't really no because I don't know
her
um apart from obviously you know what
you hear or whatever but you think he's
traded up from you or down
definitely down
I don't know but by the way I agree I
don't you should have stayed with
someone like you oh thank you you might
have been a lot happier I think yeah
it'd been funny yeah what do you think
of King Charles with the coronation come
in everything I think it's amazing yeah
yeah did you ever meet him at the in
those days yeah I did obviously I can't
really say too much about it he did he
was a lovely guy yeah just to be clear
you signed an MDA have you worked as a
groom at home like everybody works there
so that's why you can't talk about your
employment no as a man how did you find
him in good hands with him as harmonic
yeah yeah he's yeah personally I think
he's a lovely guy yeah and I think same
as William I think you know you can ask
for anyone nicer really but that's my
own View and they treated me really well
what happens to you now would you you
talked about earlier about you know
going back under your rock is that what
you want to do yeah I kind of I think
this is a means to an end you know I
just it's done I don't have to worry
um you know when it all flares up
everyone knows it's done it's dusted I
can go back to living my normal little
life driving my diggers being happy and
not having to look over my shoulder and
open my door one day and hundreds of
cameras being there I just I've always
been slightly in the back of your mind
it has I think as any mother would know
when you have little kids your
protective side comes out and I think to
to take control of this you have to come
out and control it because otherwise one
day you're just going to wake up and
you're going to have no control and you
know you've got this damage limitation
yes and I think you've limited the
damage extremely well actually hopefully
because you come over just as a decent
person yeah who didn't want any of this
had your privacy invaded again
ironically by the prince of privacy we
just saw a picture of you in the Digger
let's get that back up because
just don't look at you and think this is
someone who drives these monstrous
diggers yeah you obviously love it I do
I do I mean I worked as a groom for
quite a while and then obviously the
hours and stuff and dad has always done
groundworks and he kind of said to me
well I said Tim I didn't know what I
want to do anymore so you said well work
for me until you know what you want to
do
um and back then being a girl on site is
a little bit strange I can remember to
put my hair up and wear a coat
um but I love it I love it and I think
that you know it's a real opportunity
for other females to maybe
come out come and do building work it's
brilliant it's a great place to be
yeah what does it mean to you to be
British
I said a little bit of the start there
that to me someone like you represents
like old-fashioned British values you
know the the fact that you had dignity
and decency you didn't sell your story
you didn't betray this great secret that
you could do at any moment to me that's
kind of old-fashioned British
um I mean I was brought up with you know
you work hard you play hard you know you
don't uh you don't look dirty laundry
and you know you mind your own business
um you don't get involved in something
that you don't want to get involved in
and I just think yeah I just I think
it's just where I've been brought up but
you're quite looking forward to going
back to relative anonymity again I am
yes yep I'm quite looking forward to
getting back in my degree I've been back
in that Pub no are you going to
um probably not
no probably not you must have had other
friends who knew nothing about this I've
now picked up the sun yeah and seen you
all over the front page you've got what
yeah I mean it's something I I rarely
talked about so obviously moving from
where I lived with my parents to where I
lived now a lot of my friends would
wouldn't even know that I knew Harry or
you know had anything to do with the
royal family back then
um so for them it was a great shop when
they seen my picture that had flared up
when they were trying to find the lady
um and I was a little bit like oh yeah
that was many moons ago and then
suddenly now it's front page of
everything um but you know what it's
it's like ripping a plaster off really
yeah you feel relieved in a way it's
done I don't have to worry I don't have
to worry that people are going to turn
up at my house and start you know asking
me questions and I'm not ready for it
I'm you know it's done if Prince Harry
is watching this yeah maybe in Montecito
in his mansion
what would you say to him
I would say if you're about hook up
let's have a drink catch up chill out
whatever just be happy drink even drinks
flaming sambucas anymore I don't know
probably not looks like he needs one he
does yeah what do you think perhaps I
should take him a tray of shots and just
just talk it over I actually think you
need to try a shot and he needs a bit of
old kind of West country Common Sense
ages yeah don't you think West country
happiness I feel I feel like he needs a
bit of straight talking from someone who
knew him in his old life yeah I mean
like I said I haven't seen it for 21
years and I'd be more than happy to sit
down and talk it out but he probably
wouldn't want to know what advice would
you give him
just be happy life is too short and make
up pick your battles make you yeah
sometimes silence is better than nothing
but yeah we'll see well listen it's been
great to meet you yep uh I didn't even
know who you were we could go now we all
know who you are no I know um you're
gonna have to live with that it's a
weird thing to live with it is but
you've talked about it very I think with
you know great modesty and I completely
understand why you've decided to talk
out because otherwise it just happens
anyway right it is it's either you
control it or controls you and you know
this way it leaves everyone else Alone
um they know who it is job done Sasha
back to your Digger thank you it's
lovely to meet you and you thank you
very much